[Music]
the DeLorean sports car was manufactured
in Northern Ireland in the early 1980s
with galling doors and brushed stainless
steel panels the DeLorean was known for
its flashy style today many of these
cars are in rough shape but a
restoration can make a DeLorean look
like new this DeLorean is a rare relic
from the 80s only 9,000 80 of these
iconic cars were manufactured no longer
operational this DeLorean might have
been destined for the junkyard but with
professional restoration this company
has the spare parts to get it up and
running the process starts with the
diagnostics the technician examines the
suspension the steering rack and brakes
he finds significant deterioration and
documents his findings he scrutinizes
every part of the old DeLorean and
produces an 11 page report on its
condition once all the problems have
been identified the mechanic gets to
work removing plugs to drain some of the
coolant he disassembles many pipes and
hoses that run : from the radiator to
the rear engine many of the coolant
pipes will need to be cleaned in order
to be reused the rubber hoses can't be
salvaged and will need replacement the
mechanic disassembles the brakes the
calipers are in bad shape but can be
rebuilt the rusty rotors are still thick
enough that they can be resurfaced after
mounting new tires and refinishing the
cast alloy wheels another technician
bolts them to the hubs
he lowers the hoist and sets the car on
the floor he tightens the lug nuts to
the final torque setting a technician
begins disassembling the rear drive
engine in order to know what needs to be
replaced the technician must take the
engine apart he removes the air filter
box in order to access the intake
manifold then he unbolts the W shaped
manifold pipe that splits the airflow to
the engine once it's off he removes the
air mixture control unit which needs
restorative work with the unit out of
the way he can easily get to other parts
that need replacing or fixing those
include spark plugs wires vacuum lines
the distributor cap and rotor under the
front hood the mechanic pulls the fuel
pump out of the gas tank to check for
deterioration it's beyond repair he
drains any fuel that remains in the tank
after the gas tank has been emptied and
cleaned he inserts a new modern style
pump module another technician holds the
top of the pump down as the module is
clamped into place next the technician
removes the interior door panels and
uses a central tester to operate the
power windows he confirms the power
windows are functional he also checks
the power locks and mirrors to verify
that they're working properly he pulls
off exterior rubber trim he shaves off
any remaining rubber bits this allows
room to repair a dent in the stainless
steel body he files the area around the
dent to remove some scratches
he places a special tool over the dent
it has a rod with a fine steel tip that
welds to the body providing a solid grip
as he manually pulls out the dent
meanwhile another mechanic applies tape
to various sections of the car to
establish borders for the refinishing of
the steel body panels he sands out any
imperfections or tool marks from the
repairs and restores the brushed finish
bumper-to-bumper since no paint can be
used to cover up repairs on bare
stainless steel the bodywork must be
done perfectly inside technicians
reupholster the seats and treat any
discoloration in the vinyl panels and
dashboard finally the entire car gets an
extensive exterior cleaning it's taken
months to restore this DeLorean but the
question remains will run like a new car
once tested in various driving
conditions mechanics confirm that this
1980s throwback is ready for its
comeback